oh you know I'm ready ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to your
absolutely favorite
[Music]
ah all right yeah welcome back this is a
special episode of Ripper with Griffin I
finally got this little fat [ __ ] to come
on the show head is 86 percent of his
body fat you got a deep-ass belly button
head is so big but I finally got him to
come on so welcome to the podcast a very
special my friend you know who it is
[Music]
all right ja there it is mr. Bobby
leaves on the podcast he's you know we
facetimed didn't even Skype this time
FaceTime like I'm getting a tech worked
out now there's still gonna be some
technical issues now last week it was my
sound in the beginning it was echo II
this time my sound is gonna go out of
sync I know what it is it's a frames per
second thing with the two different
recordings because I'm recording him and
I'm recording me at a nudist [ __ ] right
but future episodes is gonna be good as
you can see right now I got a new
overlay and that's mr. Michael yáñez
shout-out to you thanks for the work
that you've done and there's some other
he's helped me out with my twitch
channel 2 which is Eric Griffin gaming
and I'm also on YouTube Eric Griffin
gaming but anyways here's another
episode I'm still trying to keep the
content pumping out I love talking to my
good buddies see how they're doing
and this is no exception lace gentleman
again welcome to the podcast my good
buddy mr. Bobby Lee enjoy yeah the
glasses ain't gonna [ __ ] work yeah
glass isn't gonna work bro it's good
though I got you we already started this
is a different one so I'm gonna do a
intro by myself so here we are mr. Barry
warms wait wait okay you know what get
it all out just talk all you [ __ ] you
get a talk just get it out you like
observing me yeah just sometimes you're
just a nightmare man
why why is it a nightmare to him I'm so
kalila draws a piece of [ __ ] with a
mustache on it it's clearly you and you
have to tell all of America hiding at
home on quarantine that it looks like me
right
but can I say this please as soon as I
said that I'd Spada texted me lights out
was canceled because you were on it you
know you hear you're like no it's so
funny that you say that it's such a
curse if my appearance canceled that
show then that's me oh man how you
holding up though dude you know you are
we talk [ __ ] about each other but you
are my one of my dearest friends yeah
how am i holding up yeah well first of
all
I like it because there's a lot of
comedians that generally don't text me
or have any kind of you know exchange
with me ever right right they've reached
out and asked how I'm doing so that
feels good I guess so yeah that's a
positive secondly um I get to eat things
that generally I don't eat like for
instance lumo not eats pizzas we get the
Liberty Chicago these frozen pizzas
right six-packs so every other day is a
pizza day for me so that's a good thing
and then the third thing is is that you
know um I haven't really been had time
to catch up on certain video games like
oh girl oh I did The Witcher how is that
fun yeah I wanted to get that too I ever
since that did you see the series no
that's why I mean I knew that the series
was coming out or it's out and I was
like I should play the game I really
like the game it's fun um I've been also
playing this other thing called Verizon
something something or another that was
a ps4 hit back in the day also you never
got the Xbox ah you're still playing on
a ps4 yeah yeah yeah I have a ps4 the
reason why no I don't got my xbox is
because I know that I'll get sucked into
other videos you're world with my hey I
have a ps4 I can I can we can get FIFA
and let play FIFA on ps4 whatever you
want man or like whatever yeah I don't
have your ps4 name I'm gonna get alive
alright yeah same thing yeah I'm Eric
let's play some let's play some games
man that stuff is fun we don't got to
play the ones that make us yell even
though we just get super competitive
when we play it what else are you
playing I'm playing modern warfare I
just love that game you know it's
actually cross-platform which is pretty
dope it is free it's a free game it's
called modern warfare yeah but it's just
like that Battle Royale stuff I
fortnight you know yeah oh we could be
on the same team I mean I would like to
kill you but be on the same team is good
yeah I know but I don't know I've been
playing that I still been playing
destiny I've been playing they had this
other game called what's it called
I forgot all the games they're all like
to me I've been playing those games you
know you know I've been playing on a lot
of stardew valley as well that's what I
hear apparently that all the internet
knows about it cuz they key every time
I'm online they go why is it Bobby
playing this game I just like you like
loners by yourselves no I like I like
simulation games I like building things
I like designing certain things right
like having a farm and being able to
like have it work you know accordingly
you know and I always got me hooked on
sims that [ __ ] sim I don't know I
know I know I don't like sims I like
farming oh but but um but that they have
that on ps4 or you've been playing it on
your phone every platform you can get on
yeah you can get you know you played
mine
have you ever play minecraft I've you
know I've thought about it I just I just
don't know much about it I don't know
much about it either and the graphics
are so [ __ ] but apparently people go
crazy for it all the building and stuff
and I just yeah I put it on my computer
I started to play a little bit and I was
like what the [ __ ] is this I'm a little
bougie about that kind of stuff so I
don't know but I'm still playing I'll
get out my ps4 sitting right on my desk
I can't hook what I love about the ps4
and the Xbox it's the same cord you can
just take the power cord out and put it
in the other one and you know all that
so you could just have my first let's
talk about what you want to talk about
let's talk about what you think let's
talk about what is gonna happen in the
next two or three months you think you
guys think about the comp in the comedy
business well first of all what we
learned from that comedy thing that you
did yesterday is that comedy actually
might be dead you know like you were
great your fury the thing you were being
yourself but I think a lot of people are
finding out that comedians without an
audience microphone or lights and
cameras they might not be as engaging as
they they think that they are Bobby move
to your right a little bit yeah like
that perfect yeah they might yet so I
don't know I think we're gonna have to
try to reinvent what the comedy is
and how its presented in the next two or
three months unless they come up with a
vaccine because are going to live
performances it's not gonna come back
until they this is stopped you know Gary
you know it is scary it's scary to think
like you like the Comedy Store even
someplace like the Staples Center or
like him
whiskey go-go or like think of all these
iconic places on Sunset that the last
factory that like you know have the
house people that they can't do that
anymore and I don't know when it's gonna
come back and it's it's scary I find
myself going stir-crazy we just would
not have in that outlet that's why I
love doing the podcast I love being
creative you know here's the thing about
here's here's the thing about the
podcast world doll and I have some
gripes I have to say I'm gonna tell me
please alright so some of us you know
what and some of us were almost forced
into doing podcasts out of survival
right all right sick for me I had always
had big dreams of doing big Hollywood
things right uh but they just it just
didn't work out the way I wanted it to
work out you know I've been on sitcoms I
that's kinda like you and that's
collected kind of like the podcast you
were gonna do with me and I just didn't
work out but I get it go on you wanted
to do big Hollywood things so you got a
white guy but I understand let's go
let's get to you but what you're saying
alright let's get it out of the way it's
my only great Bobby right I wish you
would have just told me that you didn't
want to do the podcast with me I wish
you just said that I wish you would have
just said you know what this is it was
gonna go better it's a much more
conducive if I do it with Santino he's
got a bigger following and and then
together we could do this I would have I
would have been fine with that but you
came at me like oh we're gonna do it and
then you know next thing you know you're
not gonna do it and then you you know
you try to use your father's death and
to guilt me into like being okay with it
you know I wish she was just been
straight up with me just be straight up
with me I would have been so much more
happy I would have been like okay I get
it you don't say
get it you don't think I get it huh
you're so wrong about this okay tell me
Tom I'm being this is what you have to
know about me all right okay I don't
want to do anything I don't want to do
any of it and that's that's the honest
truth
you know that that's why I don't want to
do anything with anybody here's the
thing is is that they're just certain
people that are so aggressive that I
respond to and the way Andrew came to me
and he was relentless
okay it was so he strong-armed you into
this pocket was it that's basically what
he strong-armed me into the situation
and the penises and and you and I have a
different kind of banter right you're
not as aggressive you're loving and
caring and loving and caring so it you
know I mean it was I was almost coerced
into doing it what again like all kinds
you would have just said that to me if
you would've just said it's now you five
no but like you had me go through all
this stuff and then I gotta hear all
this into it we're all here something
we're squashed okay I'm just tell you
it's squash sorry thank you thank you
that's all I wanted it does it does
Bobby Lee apologizes - all right so I
was so calm - go on podcasting podcaster
yes let's go focus comics right have
been forced and I know I did podcast
because you know I think it was a skill
set that I was okay I'm kind of honest
and forthright you're great you can say
that I'll say you're great you know a
lot of podcasts have said Oh Bobby Lee
is OK at this you know so I you know I
knew that it was a skill set that I
could take advantage and I can a idea
podcast because of the fact first of all
you know the kalila right is the one
that wanted to the podcast tiger belly
started because she wanted to do her
podcast she started it and then I see
also told me how she don't want to do a
podcast with me she told me to
but she was close to my face is that so
you know I do a podcast because I wanted
to help my road numbers and also it's
something that um I was kind of you know
I had to do it to survive but now you
see a lot of these guys doing it it's
like you know because it's the cool
thing to do
yeah right and it's like I want to say
Stan you're [ __ ] lame bro you know
you're [ __ ] lame I have to play nice
I have to go oh congratulations you have
won - yeah for you well the thing is
like you were saying earlier the
question you asked him I like what do
you think the state of Connie's gonna be
in two or three months I mean I think
all this stuff is gonna get weeded out I
mean it's just like you know all the
online listen just because you have a
podcast doesn't mean people gonna listen
to it it's hard for me to even get
people to come to my podcast which is
just me so I'd do all kinds of different
things and I started a podcast for
similar reasons it was like everybody
was doing it you were doing it you know
and then I went on Rogen's podcast and
like it's the first time I ever got
bonuses at the Irvine improv the weekend
after doing Rogan and I was like oh so
this is real and so I was kicking myself
like I wish I would have started it
earlier and now that this is going on
I'm so good I started it when I did cuz
the whatever little money that comes in
for this for me it's gonna keep me
afloat until we figure out what the
[ __ ] going on in the world but a lot
of people who weren't even necessarily
whatever we want to call making it in
stand-up so now they're like really
scrambling either like you know my
problem isn't with those people Oh got
you
it's what the people is with the dudes
that have already made it oh right right
right I get it boredom out of boredom
now they're like and let's just say
maybe one of them could be Asian but I'm
not saying that he is have a partner
like famous people just stop keep going
all right
see no evil hear no evil [ __ ] you I
don't know you're doing oh yeah it's not
even just it's a trust me imagine I know
actors right a lot of actors are in some
lot of them are my friends right in it
and it's a broad thing it's the comedy
no I know what you're saying though it
no you know what just reminds me of it
reminds me of like remember like 10
years ago when all those like like
actors started doing stand-up and then
they were taken to spots at the clubs
and you know yeah so now they're doing
that here's another point this is that
all right so when vine happen yeah right
and people were getting followers on
vine like will will sasso my friend was
a big Britney for a lot of friend of
mine a friend of mine too I didn't do it
because I'm like you know what I jumped
on this bandwagon way too late
right there are the kings of this don't
domain right and I'm gonna stay in my
[ __ ] lame yeah all right so that's
the thing staying your [ __ ] limb but
they don't know and and they're not
going to and then they're gonna and it's
gonna you know it's gonna change this
thing is gonna change
yeah well and then now it's just
the market seems to be it's gonna be so
saturated but I think there's enough you
know this the Internet is so vast you
know you YouTube there's so many
different channels on YouTube I mean
there's people on YouTube they get
millions of views that have nothing to
do with comedy and pod can podcast or
anything like that but they they have
channels that get millions of views that
dwarf anything that like some comics do
so it doesn't matter there's enough
space for everybody I mean you really
think it's gonna take up the space do
you miss doing stand-up yeah you know
what I missed is um and I didn't think I
would ever miss this but I miss even
seeing my enemies you know I miss seeing
the drama I miss seeing you know I miss
showing up the store or pulling up and
saying hi to my friend yeah and you know
and us going out to eat afterwards and
you know just that whole thing you know
I'm human human interaction you know
yeah say this I think that this this you
know this event this pandemic is gonna
change a lot of attitudes in the comedy
world I think that like there are people
that like Marc Maron for instance yeah
who I love in he's not one of the kind
of guys that would be like if I had
cancer I don't know if he would text me
but he has been reaching up oh you do
yeah yeah it's and it's like you know I
think that there's a lot of people that
it's it's softening people and it's um
kind of uniting us and I remember you
called me like two days in a row and I
was kind of like wow this is different
but I get it yeah I mean I get it I mean
it's just it's just one of these things
were like IIIi I used to say all the
time I the people think the phone is
enough like young people think like well
we're connected with our snapchat and a
Twitter and all this stuff
but it's literally not enough and now
they're seeing it I see these like rich
celebrities like rappers and they're in
their big mansion and they're they're
tweeting out like I'm so bored and I'm
like damn even it went even from the
outside people would see those people
that say they have everything but
people are missing the thing that we all
need we're communal creatures and now
we're we're you know we're trying to not
kill our loved ones that are close to us
yeah you know and that and that is
[ __ ] hard yeah but I've made an
adjustment cuz Rachel's with me and it's
just like a cake at first it was like I
was like whoa I don't know if I could do
this yeah yeah I don't live with you
either
yeah Jesus I know that's not even nobody
talked about that was aim funding no
it's like your neck like you're a dream
there's no way I would be able to
[ __ ] live with you oh my god what are
you talking about my hair in your hair's
you wouldn't even have no little
difference no one smells like you know
but my worry is um just as a society as
a whole and um it would you think of um
Trump uh retweeting Joe Rogan he did I
don't even see that today here um tweet
on I'll drop a Trump retweeted four or
five Joe Rogan things because Joe and I
don't have an opinion about this well it
sounds like you have an opinion
well what did Joe say oh you know what
basically said that I would tend to
maybe vote for Trump over by them Wow
yeah and then Trump retweeted oh man
yeah so I wonder how Joe feels about
that and be like but if you look at
Joe's tweets he hasn't really mentioned
anything so uh well because you have to
like you have to be silent now now it's
like oh that's why Andy Kindler was
talking [ __ ] about Joe Rogan I was
wondering why I was actually gonna text
Joe and be like did you and Andy Kindler
have like a fight and now I get it now
it makes sense yeah
when I saw it well I'll be honest with
you you know I mean at the end of the
day is Biden the best nomination
um does he have some shady history yeah
um is he a part of the establishment
yeah is he a better choice maybe
but but you know it's but but but Roman
has a big yeah yeah huge audience and
that was a significant thing I think it
was I think because you know cuz I think
it's gonna embolden to me there is a
certain crowd that also follows Joe that
let's say is not left at all you know
what I mean yeah in the spine um and
it's totally fine I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm not talking [ __ ] about these
people at all but I'm just saying it's
like but they're now gonna be like oh
let me be louder with my voice now it's
like you know if this guy that I follow
and I and I learned a lot of things from
and he has a lot of smart people on his
podcast and I and I and I love listening
to this guy and he just said something
that some people believe now they're
gonna be like oh yes now let me that's
us speak out even more so I don't know
but you know what drives me crazy
more than that is there some lefties you
know me on Instagram Twitter and whatnot
and saying well who's Jill Rogen anyway
oh now now right you now all of a sudden
he's the biggest podcast planet Earth
yeah yeah yeah right he's got millions
of followers on this red go [ __ ]
yourself it is a significant thing well
a lot of the hypocrisy to of like what's
going on with the quarantine and
everything to is like I I'm just like
it's so layered but then you have these
people out here talking about like stay
at home alright and then they're on
their high horse about stay at home
right but these same people are ordering
Amazon as if those people that work at
grocery stores and are coming to your
place they don't have families they
shouldn't stay home either so it's like
don't be like well we should all stay at
home and then also be ordering every
other week stuff - you're like Eric
people have to survive right
I understand but that's what I'm saying
what I'm saying is don't take a certain
position because it's layered like I
think I think in some cases people
should shut their mouths that's what I'm
saying
I just I don't I don't know if like
constantly talking about you know stay
home stay home stay home stay home but
then your order order order order and
say let's also remember that there
are other people out there that we
empathy and support and love to their
household we don't order her every day
obviously you know like for instance you
know I've this is not a good thing but I
bomb gone back to smoking cigarettes
which is not a good thing and I want to
quit okay we need to especially with
this thing respirator system you're a
come on man
oh that's why I'm being very precautious
because I feel like I'm one of those
guys that if I get it I'm gonna die and
I know you and I've had that argument
before that you said you wouldn't die
hey you know what make a joke help
listen we're making jokes by 39 didn't
say that but here the thing is we don't
it affects everybody differently man I
know you know it just there's no like
there's people that are super healthy
that got really really sick and then
there's some people that are like not
really healthy and they have they only
got like smell and taste so it affects
people differently you know what I mean
you and I you and I get that we die [ __ ]
you you wanna get anybody I don't care
what [ __ ] health supplements you're
taking and what [ __ ] vitamins and
what health yeah I'm being healthy you
ever seen out slim down you piece of
[ __ ] it's like wow you really have to be
like this you can't give me one you
can't say one nice thing about me huh
it's look how hard it is for you to be
like I think you're hilarious diet oh my
goodness dude you're a giver you know
what yeah you know what Rachel I do this
thing where we call a foul you know you
say something [ __ ] up you go foul and
now you have to say two nice things
about the other person yeah I'm not
doing these days yes we have to do that
you and I need to be doing that not
playing foul again technical foul on the
league alright so if we both get it by
god okay I'm staying home I'm not gonna
get it but you know that being said you
know I smoked it and that's why when I
do like every other like every other
week we got we put on our mat the gloves
on we go to 7-eleven mm-hmm do a thing
so that I get
I mean cigarettes I don't do it every
day so I make sure that I get so much
right enough to last me for a couple
weeks right right you know so you have
to be mindful about yeah are you using
yeah I'm just say be mindful of like the
things that you're saying to that just
you know the Internet it could be a
toxic place and now we're just honored
all the time you know what I mean listen
I don't want this whole thing to be like
so morbid and all that kind of stuff too
I mean there's nothing funny about
nothing yeah well I was gonna you know
talk to me about what you're watching I
you know I don't want to know what what
things you're catching up on what have
you seen have you been watching up but
cuz I know you're mr. documentary have
you been watching some of these done in
Toronto I saw the tiger thing you know
you didn't like it
you know I loved it you know but you
know it's you know but
it's not the best series I've seen I
think that I I think when you and I saw
making a murderer no more conversational
and we I think I think it I think it had
we had a visceral like just emotional
effect that had on us but yeah you know
we know when we look back on that like
what is it now five six years later yeah
you know and to know that isn't the kid
still in jail yeah and then the other
guy still in jail so it told me that my
faith in documentaries started to waver
because if all that evidence that was
presented in that documentary in the way
that it was presented for those people
to still be in jail we don't know all
the information yeah but it did the
documentary still helped with the what's
at the on the Wichita the Wichita three
or whatever the does all right right
right right
so yeah the same you know what right I
know the one you're talking to a co
documentaries and then also Peter
Jackson produced one that's that those
boys are out so you know documentaries
do have a power you know but I mean I
think they start a conversation and in
and then the in that particular case
they actually found the killer so that's
you know that that's a little different
I mean with that making a murder I mean
it'd be different if I thought they
never found the killer of no but they
found yet they did they found evidence
that they found no one was ever charged
for it alright I get you say but they
found enough circumstantial evidence to
point to someone else that it was like
you know like this thing with making a
murderers like you know I like if the
girlfriend
if the girlfriend's like in Bahamas
right now quarantine and you know they
catch her at a store you know think then
that I would love to see that you know
cuz yeah you know just making sense and
you know I mean there's so many things
about that documentary that I still
think about and I go but it makes me mad
because like I said I think that they
left out some very they told a story
they had a narrative and we bought it
you know what I mean I'd like to express
to your viewers my favorite
documentaries please in the last 10 or
15 years if I may go ahead do you ever
see the imposter
is that the one where the guy what like
somebody was kidnapped and then he comes
back and says that it's him yeah yeah I
saw that one does [ __ ] real good
man but real start to look at you go you
don't look nothing like it's crazy to be
believed here's my second dear dear
Zachary I haven't seen that one I'll
watch it though
oh my god I'm Eric I am for you I will
watch dear Zachary your fat little heart
will break what why does it gotta be fat
just cute that's another foul for you so
you don't say you're just a good part of
rules is it can't be about your looks
you have to say something about my
personality and how I you know okay you
know I'm so sorry I want to change you
have to change Jesus Christ man what if
I do get sick and I'm a but it would be
it would it would [ __ ] destroy me if
you died that would have you I have a
documentary label if I died if you died
it would be it would be very sad you
know I would be sad you know how sad it
would be sad you know and I would take
over Tiger belly with kalila and I would
just you know keep it going in your
honor you know what I mean I have some
more document I see don't mind I have
one guy gave me one that I like I just
saw it I wanted to get the title right
how to fix the drug scandal have you
seen that one on Netflix bro this is
about this like this the drug inspector
the job that works for the police she
was a drug addict okay two of them this
one she was a drug addict and she was
taking the drugs and she was signing it
so she was falsifying the drug reports
on me all these cases while she was
taking the drugs and then for like 10 12
13 years and they ended up letting out
like 35,000 drug offenders because it
nullified all that stuff I mean it's
just crazy and with the lawyer in our
lawyer was
that's what I would do as a pharmacist
Oh God
we know we ran out of oxycontin so that
what that's on Netflix that's on Netflix
yeah thought you could come give me
another one capturing the Friedman's
it's old-school capturing the freeze I
don't know no I don't know where you can
see it but it's a [ __ ] classic write
it down treatment it's so sensational
I'm so good you're gonna love it
I'm gonna check that one out too did you
see I Aaron Hernandez one oh yeah you
know some of these he did it you know
what I'm noticing about a lot of these
documentaries is they're so sad like
this just this Tiger King one like I was
like all of these people are terrible
like there wasn't anyone in that
documentary that like except for the
asian girl that got her arm bitten off
she wasn't [ __ ] asian you [ __ ] it
she was Asian me you know Filipino is an
Indian or something she like Filipino
you know American Indian you're you
piece of [ __ ] anyways she just looked
whatever that poor girl who got her arm
bitten off she was the only one that had
some sense and the one guy that left his
wife at the end he was the other guy
that I thought these two people seemed
to be okay but everyone else was just
like criminals and cult leaders and sex
addicts and drug addicts and like it was
just crazy I didn't see it that way I
found them to be very interesting
characters oh yes and also they're
essentially being themselves and I think
that they have a lot of like um flaws
obviously I'm afraid at least a lot of
flaws but I think that some of those
flaws that we can relate to you know I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah yes so um I know I
found it to be maybe like homage to as
other people found it no I found them to
be like I thought they were all like
cult leaders you know yeah let's say
that they weren't doing the tiger [ __ ]
or though that they could be they could
have been like the most dynamic plumbers
or
are like church people or or even
comedians I mean imagine like we know
comedians that are like very charismatic
and have a lot of like followers have a
lot of people like they just were like
these fascinating Kenny were all the
same tonight like CD yeah yeah yes like
CB he's having right there CD I do not
know who I'm talking about all right but
that [ __ ] CD in any other time period
yeah he would have been a [ __ ] cult
leader yeah he would have been Jim Jones
something even weirder yeah I agree
he would have had like a like a combine
someplace you know what I'm saying he
what else comment Bryan Callen yeah yeah
just look at Joe Rogan Joe was like you
know his thing that he has easily could
be at a church in Utah charismatic it
just charismatic in like so these guys
in that documentary were very much like
that they just were but even even Carol
Baskin she herself was a cult leader she
has you know they all essentially are
the same people essentially all the same
her to makes it fascinating yes it was
very fascinating yeah give me another
one I like to hear what your document is
come trying to why I need so many
recommendations because I've gone
through I'm just going through [ __ ] like
this and I watched all of season three
of uh what's the Jason Bateman one I
watched that already yeah Ozark Ozarks I
watch Ozarks already i watch you know
I'm watching hunters right now on Amazon
that's really good with Al Pacino Oh
Jordan Peele show yeah oh is that Jordan
Peele show yeah oh [ __ ]
got another show he didn't put you on
right he's another one that's been
texting me a lot doing this oh good yeah
yeah yeah now he's now he's gonna be
like now he's gonna be like I got a
project for you but all we're quarantine
it's the perfect time to reach out you
know here's the thing with that
you know I honestly
I'm a specific type of person to cast in
something yeah you know I mean it's not
like you can fit me into certain things
it has to be very specific so you know I
do have a lot of friends and so do you
have a lot of friends that do big
projects and stuff that you're sometimes
mean we might you know people come even
close or whatever you think that it's
like you know I don't I'm not
[ __ ] you I'm talking about me although
you might fit in the same category is
that no it's it's you know I'm a
specific I get it I love a guy you know
I mean I can't really play a lot of
things I don't think that people don't I
think that I can but you know I look at
yeah I was sometimes when I'm just bored
and I'm going through these Netflix like
I look at that I go to the series and
then I see like there are so many series
on Netflix that are new 2019 2020 and I
look at them and I go why didn't I go
out for somebody so many but without you
know the thing is is that in many ways
you know I've thought about that too and
it's so saturated does it matter
ya know what you mean for sure cuz only
certain things hit I mean like likes
look how many documentaries are on
Netflix that don't get like sometimes I
think they hit like Tiger king hit right
yeah there's other ones that you go that
was way better but it just just doesn't
so I know just do one thing I almost got
stranger things
Oh like I Oh more like I was I mean I
don't want to get into middle nickname
not angry but it was a totally
disappointing morning yeah I went in
read a couple times and they wanted me
for one part didn't work out whatever
and then I it didn't happen but um so
it's like that one hurt but there are a
lot of things that I went out for and
then it came out that didn't get and in
many ways I'm like I'm so glad I didn't
get that or it's like there's so many
things that like I know a lot of people
that are in a lot of series that don't
have a lot of money and that are arm
still trying to figure out what the next
thing is yeah yeah necessarily so I
don't really take those things
personally you know it's like of course
of course but you want to work don't you
you you you're greater you just want to
work don't you
you've worked with Jennifer Aniston
you've worked with Patrick Stewart yeah
you were on that show time show you and
I did a movie with John Austin I know
right yeah we're sorry no yeah we've
done a lot you know I've done my share
of a lot of these and things so it's
like you know I don't I have I've had my
shot I've been on series and I'm okay
with where my life is
yeah well that's good right do you but
do you feel coming off of everything
that has happened in the past few months
you know with the death of your father
and the rehab and like and now this
quarantine I mean do you feel like
you're at a different place in your life
I mean do you feel different than you
were six months ago you know
cuz you seem different Bobby I'm telling
you I talked about it in one [ __ ] way
you see you use you feel more connected
you feel you feel more present you know
like you just you just like when you're
in the hallways you're like you don't
have this as manic of energy as you had
before where you'd be like zipping
around all over the place you guys see
you taking a moment to like enjoy the
surroundings and talking to people and
then you still leave because you know
you still have a little bit of that but
I just feel like it you're you're in a
different place I feel like you're like
turned a corner and now you're dealing a
new chapter in your life
here's the thing Rogan once told me
view of your life she said this maybe
seven months ago like right when my dad
died he goes mirror life like you're in
the star grown you know and so you know
I decided when they deal with my dad's
trauma I'm going to get sober
this whole throwing a virus thing in the
last twelve months of my life has been
[ __ ] group yeah so much has happened
so much tragedy and so many good things
and bad things show gets canceled dad
died relapsed
I mean Harkness is doing good I mean and
then I got my show got stole but you
know I sold the show
and then the coronavirus I don't know
what's gonna you know but you know what
this is life and it's like I'm just you
know if I didn't live the kind of life
that I don't experience much because
they don't take risks and they don't
really go out there and and go for it
and yeah people live in fear yeah and
because of the fact that you know I
don't know why I have no skills I really
don't I don't know much about it I don't
I really don't know much about anything
I have no education I never read a book
but the one thing that I've always had
and I've had this since I was a kid I
think is is that I'm just willing to go
and just try it mmm you know and so I'm
living a pretty big life and in life not
everything
he works out in life there's great
things and bad things but I'm just
trying to stay in the moment to
experience all of it and at the end at
the end of the day um I think that if I
did get to come on I was dying I think I
would go
I did it you know I did I mean it was
incredible you know yeah I hear you
talking right now and it's like it's
great it's beautiful Bobby I just I'm
saying I don't know if we could have
even had this conversation like we
couldn't have had this conversation say
eight months ago you're not I mean look
at you you don't you try to ruin it but
you can't you already had to turn them
up he's gonna cut all this out
save that for kalila okay that's a first
but what do you think's gonna ever go on
in the next three months you asked me
but what do you think I felt like you
have a I I think I think I think the
quarantine has to be longer than we
think I think it should be mm-hmm I
think that
if we're a little premature about this
thing and we don't nip it in the bud but
that you could show its ugly face again
so I think that wait see that's nice
yeah or you know the the the number of
cases have to dwindle substantially yeah
and they have to have and they have to
have the testing needs to be readily
available like it needs to be like you
can go to CVS you put something on your
tongue and then it says you have Corona
and then you know to go quarantine you
know it's like it has to be like the
testing and then the end why don't we
just all just pretend we have it and
just [ __ ] quarantine yourself what
they but no because they need to they
have to have the testing so they can
track it like the testing is just as
important as to quarantine yeah I know I
get it but let's just act as a society
where everyone has it unless just
[ __ ] stay in our houses for two or
three months let it let it [ __ ] ass but
let me say something when people are
still going to churches in these large
gatherings that they're doing in Georgia
where it's Florida right and they're
allowing needs to be open there are a
lot you know it's like dude Florida just
did the shutdown two or three days ago I
know you know so it's like as a country
we have to it it's hard what it's hard
when you know we don't we're not giving
like a definite message from the top but
think I know but that's the thing it's
like you know first of all
when you downplay when you downplay I'm
not saying prom I'm not saying his
administration but what I'm saying is is
that when certain people and certain
news organizations are saying
downplaying this thing as as the common
flu you mean some people you know it's
nothing you know and they did that for a
month and a half right calling it a hoax
right
you know if I'm not saying I would have
done a better job as a president but
what I'm saying is that we need somebody
we needed somebody in January to go all
right this thing in China's going on a
new Han right it's spreading the Korea
right cuz that's where it went
right Italy's you know I mean there's
some signs in Italy you need a guy to go
this week this thing should shut it down
we shut it down now yeah we shut it down
now
Bobby why is all this stuff [ __ ]
happen why does all this stuff start
always starting in Asian countries why
SARS bird flu the the hn9 whatever one
corona why is it any thoughts on it give
any thoughts of like about a lot of
these viruses or they they seem to
originate is it oh really so you think
that these viruses are starting in Japan
I don't know I'm just wondering no it's
not Japan no you think if they're
starting it's not Korea where is it
starting China you trying to get I don't
know what you're talking about
did you did you read how North Korea
said they don't have a problem with
Corona they might not know then they got
help from the UN or something that's
like some kind of a did they got but I'm
gonna lay down a bit
that's fine is okay yes good you look
good yeah I just yeah I don't know I
mean it's like you know um I don't know
exactly how it started I think it has
something to do with
ooh yeah places that don't have like
grades on their restaurants no I'm not
you know I mean I'm not a scientist and
I don't I don't know me neither
we're just about it but I've gotta swear
pinions yeah people are eating things
that they should meet maybe yeah baby
like if it's not a tas it if it started
to sit down Applebee's and like move on
like if it was like if it was like you
know to me if it was like at the
Applebee's in Wuhan and then somebody
came out of there like oh I don't feel
well that's one thing but it's like you
know if you go to a market like in in
[Music]
China for instance you know in a rural
in a rural area right you can see things
that generally like butterfly wings
annamaya German the shoulder of a
meerkat yeah
you mean right or like you know things
that are like yeah you see people
shopping to kick it up can I get a half
pound of meerkat and yeah those bat
testicles can I have yeah how about yup
marsupial eyeballs
[Laughter]
I got a documentary for you actually you
have to watch this one pandemic it's on
Netflix yeah I know I saw I didn't want
to oh dude they talked about this that
all these flus come from animals you
know yeah they talk it's just a
fascinating thing that they're saying
that this happened but this she came out
they were predicting what's happening
now they're like there will be another
major flu there would that will have to
be talked about
what's an HIV from cutting down the
rainforests right and then the and
there's an end in the virus they were in
monkeys but they'd be somehow jumped
into humans because we're putting down
the rains rainforest dude I haven't you
think I know you know why would I know
Oh what racist thing are you gonna say
right now do you want to get Hansel I
know I don't like again that's another
thing is as I you know it's that fear of
getting cancelled
I know hey you know what you know who
you know you should look to for
inspiration for getting cancelled and
coming back look at see Louie he just
came out with a special yeah you know
and a lot of comics are tweeting about
it like yeah it's like you know is it
good you see it I haven't seen because
I'm not paying for it all right
worth of that I'm gonna put this on this
website on his website and peeing on it
and and like I think I think it's genius
to be like people are starving for you
know streaming entertainment cuz they're
stuck inside you know and and then
you're people are gonna privacy their
own home so they can't be like they
can't be like shamed you know if you
want to buy it you buy it
you just look around like no you put it
to credit card information in and you
just you have the Louie special at home
they can't even try that's an a really
interesting thing because um now I'm not
you know I'm not too doning what he did
right by all means you know is it the
worst thing I've ever heard
no right right is it
if I don't worst thing you've ever heard
it's not the worst thing you ever heard
but like but you know what but let's say
the but let's say this though let's say
this though let's be be aware that we
are men so the feelings and stuff that
it inspires in people in victims of that
kind of stuff we may not understand it
and that's why we could talk about it
like this and I'm fully aware of their
and I'm empathetic to that okay but you
know when that happened he was probably
the best comic on planet earth right
right and um I'm not saying maybe huh
I mean one of them Hey yeah he was yes
yes yes he would call fine yeah call
five yeah he really was yeah yeah yeah
yeah she was one of those guys that like
even when you know it's like when Adam
Egan you know Adam Egan you know the
comedy store
Booker he's one of my very good friend I
love him so you know don't you love him
I love him and I had to text him be like
oh so you can go on he told me he
doesn't do podcasts next thing you know
I see him on Santino's I know you you
have a weird thing of resentment and
anger he said I'm not gonna die in
podcast [ __ ] sad little [ __ ] okay
Wow
so you know I want you to grow up
busting balls you know there are certain
comics that he'll wait in the parking
lot and then when they arrive you eat
personally walked around with them to
bump everybody and and not only that
y'all ask what they need and and just
kind of be there like [ __ ] for like you
know and and Louie was one of those guys
yeah he was Louie hey guys yeah Chris
Rock is one of those guys so you know he
was the Chris Rock turned out to be like
Chris Rock just in the beat just real
cool like Chris Michael just be walking
all the best guys he's such a nice guy I
just walk through the hallway with his
hat on and let you know you people don't
even realize you know they don't even I
will [ __ ] in that Chris nothing Chris
Rock is a real comedian
he really is he's like one of those guys
like he'll say hi to you just because he
knows that you're in the game yeah why
yeah he doesn't have I could name
somebody I'm not going to but there's
something there is a guy at that level
that will pretend that he does even over
the [ __ ] you are
yeah I can't stand that kind of [ __ ] I
guess so and you know who else is like
that Chappelle is like that Chappelle is
very a male let's take a selfie you know
he's like a nice guy right there just
certain ones know that I know what you
mean but but Louie is Louis was one of
those guys and he has that skill level
so it's just really interesting to me
that all I I don't know what's gonna
happen to him but does he have every
right to put up special out on his own
website
yeah it's America and that's the way you
should do it you know what I mean like
it's like so he's like okay you know you
these people say they don't like me I
don't just okay don't like me I he
filmed it in front of a live audience so
people came to watch it and then he put
it out on his site that's how it should
be done you know it's so funny I want to
say that
a lot of comics and we know there
there's certain comics that are anointed
by Netflix just live here me out mm-hmm
okay and it's almost is the feeling of
being anointed to being invited to a
specific club he is a feeling of being
wanted but people accepted but the thing
is is that at the end of the day we
could just do it ourselves yeah put it
out on our own thing but there's some
reason or another that we want to be
validated by the gatekeepers the ones
that you know yeah I want to be invited
to the cool Club like when I was in
Montreal last year Netflix had a party I
don't even know if I was invited right
walked over with Holly Mandel because I
know that I could get it with him the
festival
you mean so I walked over with Howie and
I walked in that thing and I felt I
really felt like an open mic no I did I
felt like oh do I am I even good enough
to be in here yeah yeah when at the end
of the day it's like my podcast what's
this all about
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean like my
following crushes there's yeah it's for
sure I would like I like anointed by
them so you know it already gives me
this insecurity which is like why
because by the way dude if you filmed a
special and you released it on tiger
bellies YouTube page yeah and even and
even and even bad friends the beauty
page it would get more views than any
Comedy Central special that they've put
out in a while because they only put it
on once and they don't care about it I
want I want the validation I get it and
I'll tell you why I believe that I
deserve it
industry that sucks to say that but I'm
just as cool as them yeah I agree I'm
just as good I'm just as cool and I
don't know why but I want their
validation well but it all comes down to
it all comes down to like whoever's in
charge at the time you know like look
what happened over at Comedy Central
they literally got rid of everybody
so now it's a new regime we'll see what
they decide to do and then all of a
sudden now you're like trying to you
know it's like when it's like when Tommy
was gone at the Comedy Store and then
admin Adam came in all those people that
were making headways it just all stopped
and now they had to start over
what's the same thing of these other
places like new people come in and they
might have a different opinion about you
or me or whoever else same thing can
happen at Netflix you know maybe
it's like these gatekeepers or not it's
not government assigned you know what
I'm saying it's like just somebody got
the job somebody you know did their
thing they got the job and now when that
person doesn't have that job anymore you
know then what does it mean does this
does it mean now we are all of a sudden
accepted because what we've done no it's
about that guy or girl but I want to say
this is I I love it and the right reason
why I love it is because I don't ever
want to I always want to feel like I'm
fired yes yes yes I always want to feel
like I'm up against the ropes and they
have something to prove and that like I
will show you I I need that just like
that's how I am yeah yeah that's what I
know that's what I'm saying well that's
how I get about what I'm saying like I
feel that way even and I'm and there's
smaller levels about things I'm like I
want people to come on like that's like
when I get that way about I get that way
about being a guest on people's podcast
you know yeah I feel the same way about
that I feel that it's at this day and
age it's equal to Netflix so there are
certain people that have started
podcasting they're all big I talk to
these people I see them in the hallways
I know that they're never gonna have me
on their podcast name it nickname a name
no I'm not gonna name a name a name the
name those famous people that are
starting podcast that you don't want to
talk about you know but we'll keep it in
the comedy community that's what you
know I tell younger comics to I go cuz
you know when I when I bring openers on
the road you know I know I'm very lucky
that I am selling out every show and
adding shows and yeah so these kids
these kids open up for me they go oh my
god this is amazing this is all I want I
go when you get here it won't be that
amazing and I wouldn't tell them I go
you always take yourself with you right
and the struggle is always there the
struggle is always there so just
wherever you're at accept that and just
be happy with that and live in the
moment because I'm gonna say this I do
miss the early days I know I know but
there's this huge goal that you're
trying to accomplish and it feels
daunting and it feels like I'm never
gonna do that and then when you get it
you're gonna get there you go oh man
like okay then it's you're searching for
something else to like fight for when I
was a doorman at the La Jolla Comedy
Store in 1996 all right somebody had
vomited on like you know you got a
little Comedy Store you get those you
have the main door that you walk through
to go in the showroom but you have those
two other openings right where you can
see the bar yeah right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah somebody hadn't vomited right
there right so I was on my hands and
knees just trying to scoop this vomit
and do it like this you know what are
you better scooper yeah and Paulie and
Joe Rogan had walked in there was some
sort of benefit show or something and
Joe was young but they had walked in and
they didn't say excuse me they just
popped over my body
oh right well I was like scooping up
this vomit right and I remember going
and they don't know they don't say hi
they don't know
me yeah I am just like this gookie
cookies and [ __ ] you know mean bar
back here they don't know I do ecology
don't know nothing right I just remember
feeling so humiliated
right I also remember back there in that
hallway I did an open mic and I remember
seeing this kid with glasses and he was
wearing he had this is kind of he was
kind of receding his hair he was a young
skinny kid and he had this afro right
that he wasn't black he was like um I
thought he was Mexican but and I
remember seeing this tag what's her name
because my name is Kjell and I live in
Vegas and we became good friends with
Jill coy oh and I remember in 1996
meeting him and becoming friends with
him and exchanging numbers
Nermin and I just remember like if I
would have known I didn't know that
right I didn't know then what would
happen but it's just like they're just
parts of that were I wish I could have
just just been more present right yeah
just enjoyed all those little tiny
little things you know man well it was
like the first few years for me like you
know so when I got on workaholics and
I'm like doing all that [ __ ] then it was
like you know it was like you're you're
trying to think like oh what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen is it
then I found I find I treat it like
sports I shoot it like football so I go
I have my game Sunday enjoy the win on
Monday and then Tuesday that's when you
start for the next thing so I enjoyed
things that I do the things that I have
but then I'm ready for the next game you
know lady for the next game I hated you
when I first met you what what does it
hate know how we met
how Amanda met show oh no Tony wait a
minute yeah I'm fine I've put that out
of my mind you hated me you I thought
you were piece of [ __ ] you what did I do
I had to deal with your diva bullsh you
were the most d almost I was gonna I was
gonna punch you in the face I had to
call I think I let's call her head I
said I'm gonna kill this [ __ ]
what do I do because he had to go member
I got your [ __ ] car drove it around
so you can use so
dramatic about the shelter drove around
faster oh Jesus Christ that's the story
that's you know what you did to me you
jumped dead you jumped over me
that's what that was you were jumping
over me while I was cleaning or a trauma
is this [ __ ] guy I honestly did I was
like look at home Mike and then and then
when I this is what happened God and
when when we went to the Middle East I
know you got the Xbox that's really what
day when oh when I when I saw you
perform I guess you know it was me you
and Sebastian Maniscalco and I was like
obviously I had to watch you perform and
I was just like going oh this guy's
legit
like gonna get funny anyway how long is
this thing well we just we just did an
hour buddy
you know that's good I'm good with that
all right you know it's easy to do right
that's pretty you loved it you guys
should just Skyped me in on your stupid
do that tomorrow on horror on horrible
friends podcast you don't I mean it's
called bad friend you bit [ __ ] you know
what it's called [ __ ] I always watch
boring I'm sorry I mean bad friends I
love it babe